während über die beschlüsse und die
uneinigkeit nach den beschlüssen möchte
ich jetzt auch mit albig sprechen
mitglied des 19-köpfigen expertenrates
der bundesregierung und vorsitzende des
ethikrates sonntag guten tag frau meiner
der vorschlag des ethik rat ist er kam
er am sonntagabend gestern war dann klar
dass ergo will offenbar mehr und
schneller auch einige länder haben dann
die maßnahmen vorgezogen leute irritiert
das natürlich waren diese vorschläge und
das alles offenbar nicht einheitlich und
geschlossen genug
damit er jetzt kein missverständnis
aufkommt am sonntag hatte sich der
expertenrat geäußert nicht der ethikrat
und ich glaube da hat es dann einfach in
der folge kommunikative
abstimmungsprobleme gegeben ich glaube
die empfehlung des expertenrates waren
relativ klar trotzdem hat das rp was ja
auch im expertenrat sitzt genau wie sie
ja dann doch noch mal mehr gefordert wie
wichtig ist denn so eine gemeinsame
haltung und kommunikation für die
akzeptanz in der bevölkerung
also es ist tatsächlich so dass der
expertenrat
prinzipiell die lage aus gezielt hat und
dann ist es schon die aufgabe auch das
rk ii konkretere maßnahmen vorzuschlagen
also das hat eigentlich ganz gut
zusammen gepasst und ich glaube da hat
es dann einfach abstimmungs fragen
gegeben heute sind ja schon wieder die
beteiligten gemeinsam aufgetreten also
ich glaube da ist jetzt sehr schnell
auch der eindruck wieder erweckt worden
dass das jetzt alles wieder hand in hand
geht dann schauen wir mal jetzt
tatsächlich auf den ethikrat da sind sie
die vorsitzende und auch der hat sich
positioniert und zwar empfiehlt der
ethikrat jetzt mehrheitlich auch eine
allgemeine impfpflicht allerdings unter
auflagen das heißt ganz einig war sich
der ethikrat offenbar auch nicht 20 von
24 mitgliedern haben da zugestimmt wie
groß ist denn innerhalb ihres gremiums
da der streit
also es gibt eine wirklich große
mehrheit für die ausweitung der
impfpflicht über die schon beschlossene
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht hinaus
dass es kein allheilmittel dass es
völlig klar und wir haben uns das
wirklich auch nicht leicht gemacht
werden uns sehr sorgfältig die argumente
angeschaut
und dann gibt es noch innerhalb der
jenigen die das insgesamt unterstützen
lassen die einen sagen man sollte das
beschränken auf bestimmte risikogruppen
etwa ältere menschen und andere sagen es
wird wahrscheinlich nicht anders gehen
als dass man das gleich für alle ab 18
macht es ging uns aber tatsächlich vor
allem darum für die abgeordneten die das
ja im nächsten jahr anfang des jahres
diskutieren wollen ganz transparent die
gründe und argumente zu machen und ich
glaube das haben wir tatsächlich
geschafft was ist denn für sie sag ich
mal das schlagende argument jetzt
tatsächlich sich mehrheitlich dafür
auszusprechen
also ich denke das sind zwei dinge die
dann letztlich die große mehrheit dazu
bewogen haben die ausweitung zu
empfehlen das es ein mal dass man sagen
muss insgesamt ist die freiheits bilanz
vermutlich besser weil man ansonsten
immer wieder die freiheiten ja sehr
vieler menschen einschränken muss und
auch wenn man die freiheit das muss man
ganz offen sagen derjenigen einschränkt
die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen so
wiegt das dann in der abwägung doch
schwerer und das zweite ist dass man
eben eine faire verteilung von
belastungen auch für die zukunft braucht
dass man nicht immer wieder in die
situation kommt dass man entweder das
land runter fahren muss oder dass die
intensivstation so am limit sind weil
das einfach her belastung für ganz viele
menschen hat die längst geimpft sind und
ich denke das sind so die zwei argumente
die dann am ende des tages am stärksten
gewirkt haben trotzdem ist es so dass
das thema corinna natürlich innerhalb
der bevölkerung teils heftig diskutiert
werden manche sprechen schon von einer
spaltung der gesellschaft würden sie so
weit gehen oder ist es vielleicht eher
eine abspaltung eines vielleicht
kleineren aber dafür lauteren teils
also eine spaltung sehe ich auch
überhaupt nicht es gibt eine große
mehrheit der menschen die zwar müde sind
und total genervt absolut
nachvollziehbar viele haben viel
verloren aber die dinge mitträgt und
dann gibt es eben laute stimmen die sich
zu
dingen sehr sehr negativ verhalten aber
ich glaube man sollte einfach darauf
fokussieren was da schon erreicht wurde
und wie man das schaffen kann dass wir
alle gemeinsam im nächsten jahr wirklich
raus kommen aus dieser pandemie sagt die
vorsitzende des deutschen ethikrates und
mitglied des expertengremiums der
bundesregierung alena büxt vielen dank
für das gespräch sehr gern danke